todas las células del cuerpo humano
necesitan energía para sobrevivir y
realizar sus funciones es si pensamos en
las células del cerebro éstas necesitan
energía para estimular otras células a
su vez y que realicen sus funciones
enviando señales y mensajes que por
ejemplo las células de los músculos se
contraen y expanden y la fuente
principal de donde obtienen esta energía
es la glucosa y la glucosa pues
simplemente es azúcar si pudiéramos
probar la glucosa tendría un sabor dulce
y la glucosa llega a las células a
través de la sangre del torrente
sanguíneo
si yo dibujara aquí esto es el torrente
sanguíneo y es probable que va en esta
dirección y en el interior de la sangre
voy a dibujar estas pequeñas moléculas
de glucosa que van viajando en una
situación ideal cuando una célula
necesita energía las moléculas de
glucosa entran a la célula si la glucosa
ingresa a la célula pero desafortunada
no es así de simple para todas las
células del cuerpo humano esto es la
glucosa no ingresa a las células por sí
sola necesita de la ayuda de una hormona
que se llama insulina si esta es la
glucosa y ahora voy a dibujar la
insulina estas moléculas magenta
esta es la insulina insulina y en la
superficie de las células y hay unos
receptores de insulina que voy a
dibujarlos de una manera que
simplificada y son los lugares donde
estas moléculas magenta se pueden
sujetar se unen y la manera en la que la
glucosa ingresa a las células a través
de este mecanismo que la insulina se une
a los receptores y entonces se abren los
canales por los cuales puede ingresar la
glucosa a la célula
es hasta que esto ocurre cuando la
glucosa puede ingresar a la célula
pero bueno como en todo no todas las
cosas salen como lo planeado
ahora voy a dibujar aquí una célula
simple y voy a poner el torrente
sanguíneo
más o menos así y ahora voy a dibujar
las moléculas de glucosa que son las que
están aquí y ahora voy a poner los
receptores de insulina en la superficie
de esta célula
la primera cosa que podría salir mal es
qué pasa si este cuerpo no produce
insulina la insulina se produce en el
páncreas y qué pasa si el páncreas no la
está produciendo
a ver vamos a poner aquí no hay insulina
y entonces no se pueden adherir a los
receptores de insulina no se abren los
canales y entonces la glucosa no puede
ingresar a la célula ya esta situación
es a lo que llamamos diabetes tipo 1
diabetes tipo 1 y entonces es cuando
tenemos glucosa tenemos a los receptores
de insulina pero no tenemos insulina que
abra estos canales para que ingrese la
glucosa a la célula
y hay un segundo escenario el cual lo
voy a dibujar aquí aquí voy a poner otra
vez una célula
el torrente sanguíneo
el vuelo de estas células el cuerpo
humano tiene billones de células
aproximadamente 100 billones este
diagrama es un diagrama muy sencillo y
ahora voy a pintar otra vez las
moléculas de glucosa que van
desplazándose en el torrente sanguíneo
ahora me voy a dibujar los receptores de
insulina entonces aquí tengo uno por
aquí tengo otro y aún más es probable
que tengamos insulina como aquí es decir
en nuestro páncreas puede estar
produciendo insulina y poniéndola en el
torrente sanguíneo para que sea
utilizada pero ahora puede ser el caso
que son los receptores los que no están
trabajando bien no son sensibles a la
insulina y entonces decimos que los
receptores están de sensibilizados si
aquí luego escribir receptores de
sensibilizados los receptores no son
capaces de unir a la insulina y entonces
la glucosa no ingresa a las células
pero en cualquiera de estos dos
escenarios bueno no voy a entrar a los
detalles sino lo estoy exponiendo de una
manera general estamos enfrente de un
problema de una enfermedad
fuks observo que no le dice un hombre si
la que está arriba es diabetes tipo 1
la que está aquí abajo es diabetes tipo
2 diabetes tipo 2
y de una manera simplista una forma de
atacar este problema
digamos este primero que tenemos aquí
arriba es inyectar insulina en el
torrente sanguíneo porque el problema es
que no hay insulina entonces podemos
nosotros inyectar la la insulina
ingresar al torrente se adherirá a los
receptores y entonces la glucosa podrá
ingresar a las células
y para el caso de la diabetes tipo 2
existen varias líneas con las que
podemos atacar el problema y por ejemplo
existen algunos fármacos que pueden
volver a sensibilizar a los a los
receptores de insulina también es
posible adoptar cambios en el estilo de
vida que haga que tu cuerpo sea más
sensible al azúcar y si las cosas se
ponen realmente mal
también puedes agregar inyectar insulina
bueno me vas a decir si ya había
insulina y para qué pones más el
problema que tenemos aquí es que las
células están de sensibilizadas a la
insulina esta sería una manera de
incrementar la probabilidad de que los
receptores permitan el flujo de la
glucosa
y ya lo mencionamos hay diferentes
líneas de ataque como decíamos
utilizando fármacos que sensibilicen
otra vez a los receptores pero ahora a
lo que me quiero referir es que qué pasa
si no tomamos acciones en este escenario
si tus células no son capaces de obtener
la energía a través de la glucosa
entonces tendremos que no hay energía y
otro problema que puede surgir en este
escenario es que se incremente la
concentración de azúcar en el torrente
sanguíneo y esto puede causar problemas
severos el azúcar puede dañar el cuerpo
pues no queremos ninguna de estas
posibilidades no queremos no tener
energía y no queremos tener grandes
concentraciones de azúcar que dañen en
nuestros cuerpos